Hey, it's John Hamm. I got here early and set my tech up very quickly, so of course, I'm waiting for three idiots. Welcome to SmartLiz. Smart. Liz. Smart. Liz. Smart.
嘿，我是乔恩·哈姆。我来得早，很快就弄好了我的设备，所以当然，我在等三个白痴。欢迎来到 SmartLiz。Smart。Liz。Smart。Liz。Smart。
Liz. Smart. Liz. Liz. Smart. Liz. Oh my God, that gives me, is that Yaz? Yeah, Yaz it is.
Liz。Smart。Liz。Liz。Smart。Liz。天哪，那让我想起，那是雅丝（Yaz）乐队吗？对，就是雅丝。
That brings me back to, I met, I went to Chicago once to work the phones at a charity or a telephone. Jason, what have you done with my Jason? Yeah, and I met a girl there and she was also working the phones and we fell in love. And I was 15 and I went back home. I talked to my mom about this love I fell in with this girl in Chicago for a whole full week. She said, why don't you go back and see her?
这让我想起，我遇到过，我去过芝加哥一次，在一个慈善机构或电话中心接电话。杰森，你把我的杰森怎么了？对，我在那儿遇到一个女孩，她也在那里接电话，我们坠入爱河了。当时我15岁，然后我回家了。我跟我妈妈整整整整一个星期都在聊这段我在芝加哥跟这个女孩坠入爱河的恋情。她说，你为什么不回去看看她？
I'll take you. I'll go with you. I was like, great. My mom and I got back on a plane the following weekend, went back to Chicago and I had the most- Tell her you fell in love with a girl? Yeah, working the phone banks with me at this telephone and we had a magical weekend and that was that.
我带你去。我和你一起去。我说，太好了。我和我妈妈在接下来的周末坐飞机回去了，回到了芝加哥，我度过了最——告诉她你和一个女孩坠入爱河了？对，当时她和我在这个电话中心一起做电话募捐，我们度过了一个神奇的周末，就是这样。
All we listened to was Yaz the whole weekend. Yeah, only you. The best songs ever. Now Jason, did you know that the guy who wrote all those Yaz songs, wrote all those Erasure songs and wrote Depeche Mode songs? Really? Vince Clark. Not all of them, but a lot of them.
整个周末我们听的都是雅丝的歌。对，只有你。有史以来最好的歌。话说杰森，你知道写了所有那些雅丝歌曲的家伙，也写了所有那些伊芮丝（Erasure）的歌和赶时髦（Depeche Mode）的歌吗？真的吗？文斯·克拉克（Vince Clark）。不是全部，但很多都是。
Yeah, a bunch of them. Well, Vince Clark was the writer of Yaz and then he went to Depeche Mode and wrote, you know, just can't get enough and all those kinds of songs. Then he left Depeche Mode and went to Erasure and wrote all the songs. So now let me ask you this. Here's a little, here's a, Sean, you might know that, you probably do, the name of the lead singer of Yaz, what was her name? Alison Moyet.
对，很多都是。好吧，文斯·克拉克是雅丝的词曲作者，然后他加入了赶时髦乐队，写了，你知道的，像《根本不够》（Just Can't Get Enough）以及所有这类歌曲。然后他离开了赶时髦，加入了伊芮丝，写了所有的歌。所以现在让我问你这个。这里有个小问题，肖恩，你可能知道，你大概知道，雅丝乐队的主唱叫什么名字？她叫什么名字？艾莉森·莫耶（Alison Moyet）。
Wow. Again, I said you may know this, but yeah. Okay. Well, do you guys, did you guys know what the music festival was where Queen, Queen, Queen was the headliner and Yaz led in for them? It was called Yaz Queen and it was, it was pre, it predated Lollipalooza and I can't believe I'm laughing at that, it's so stupid, look at her, good one, Yaz Queen, even a stopped clock.
哇。再说一次，我说你可能知道这个，但好吧。好吧，你们大家，你们知道那个音乐节是什么吗，奎恩（Queen）、奎恩、奎恩是领衔乐队，而雅丝为他们暖场？那个音乐节叫雅丝·奎恩（Yaz Queen），它是在，它是，它比洛勒帕鲁扎音乐节（Lollipalooza）还要早，我真不敢相信我在笑这个，太蠢了，看看她，真好笑，雅丝·奎恩，连坏掉的时钟都有准的时候。
I want to ask you guys with the worst trouble in Uganda as a kid, because here's why, because whenever I'm like five minutes late to rehearsal, whatever, however late I am in rehearsal here in Chicago, you know, I feel like you get in trouble, like I was a kid. So I was talking to Scotty about that and Scotty's like, I asked Scotty, what's the worst trouble you got in this kid? Scotty got his mouthwashed out with soap from the nuns and Catholic school. He was about six or seven years old and he got in trouble because he was making fart noises on his arm in the bathroom.
我想问你们小时候在乌干达遇到过最糟糕的麻烦是什么，因为原因在于，每当我排练迟到五分钟什么的，无论我在芝加哥这里的排练迟到多久，你知道的，我都觉得你会惹上麻烦，就像我小时候一样。所以我跟斯科蒂谈过这个，斯科蒂说，我问斯科蒂，你小时候惹过最糟糕的麻烦是什么？斯科蒂在天主教学校被修女用肥皂洗过嘴。他当时大概六七岁，他惹麻烦是因为他在洗手间里用胳膊制造放屁的声音。
And they literally took soap and they really literally scrubbed his mouth. Why they should have scrubbed his armpit. Right. But you know what he did? Right with the soap. He breathed in to make his mouth all dry so that it wouldn't suds up. You got under eye guest or? I mean, yeah.
他们真的拿肥皂，字面意义上狠狠地刷洗了他的嘴。他们应该刷他的胳肢窝才对。没错。但你知道他做了什么吗？就用那个肥皂。他吸气让他的嘴变得很干，这样就不会起泡沫了。你眼底下有客人还是怎么的？我是说，对。
Wow. What are you, are you trying to? Will, Will, can you, can you top Scotty's, Scotty's dry wash? I mean, there have been a lot of stories of heroes over the years and that is really, people really, when they're backs against the wall are forced to come up with, right? A little bit of Scott outsmarted them, you know, there's no fluid in my mouth. So you will not get suds, ma'am. But I always thought that was like a not real thing that you got your mouthwashed out with
哇。你是，你是想？威尔，威尔，你能，你能超越斯科蒂的，斯科蒂的干洗吗？我的意思是，这些年来有很多关于英雄的故事，而那真的是，当人们被逼入绝境时被迫想出的，对吧？稍微发挥了一下，斯科蒂智胜了他们，你知道的，我嘴里没有唾液。所以你起不了泡沫，修女。但我一直以为小时候嘴被用肥皂洗过这种事是假的。
soap. But he got his mouthwashed out. That once happened to me. I, one time my mom went to hit me with a wooden spoon, true story. And I was in the kitchen and I was being mouthy, I guess. I can't imagine how and I was sweeping. I was holding a broom and I was sweeping and she went and I said to me and she went to swat me with the wooden spoon and I put the broom up to block it and it broke the wooden
但他确实被用肥皂洗了嘴。我曾经遭遇过一次。有一次我妈想用木勺打我，这是真事。我当时在厨房里，我嘴挺贫的，我想。我无法想象怎么回事，我当时在扫地。我拿着一把扫帚在扫地，她走过来，我跟她顶嘴，她举起木勺想抽我，我举起扫帚去挡，结果把木勺打断成了两半。
spoon in half. My timing was perfect and it snapped it in half and there was a moment of like, what just happened? And then we both burst into laughter. Oh, that's nice. Yeah, because you said you better step, step off just cause I was able to block her so easily. And then the whole topic of the whole topic of abuse and families is well, she went to
我的时机太完美了，把它当场劈成两半，然后有一瞬间就像是，刚才发生了什么？接着我们俩都爆发出大笑。哦，那挺好的。对，因为你说你最好识相点，就因为我能那么轻松地挡住她。然后关于家庭虐待的整个话题是，她去用木勺打我的屁股，下次她会不会拿金属锅铲来找你？因为那是我会做的事。我会吸取教训的。
hit me on the butt with the, with the wooden spoon and next time does she come at you with a metal spatula? Cause that's what I would have done. I would have learned my lesson. You know, I know it, I guess these days I don't even want to get into the broader conversation because yeah, well no, hang on a second. Let's talk about how you discipline your children and what, what you advocate for. Yeah, I want to open that up and I'd like to open it up to the world and not only that,
你知道的，我知道，我觉得现在我甚至不想卷入更广泛的讨论，因为是的，好吧，等等。让我们来谈谈你是如何管教你的孩子的，以及你主张什么。对，我想把这个话题敞开，我也想向全世界敞开，不仅如此，我还想听听他们对此的意见。他才不会做什么呢。不，当然不会。
I want to hear their opinions on it. He would never do anything. No, of course not. Guys, here we go. Hi. Ready? What if I, I got a burp. I'm not gonna burp right now.
伙计们，我们开始吧。嗨。准备好了吗？如果我，我有个嗝。我现在不打嗝。
Would this guest appreciate something like that? He wouldn't care. He wouldn't care. You didn't even wait for our answer. You said, do you mind if I burp and then you just, we're going to do it. You didn't. Why bother saying it? Was it a false alarm?
这个嘉宾会欣赏这样的事吗？他才不在乎呢。他才不在乎呢。你甚至没等我们的回答。你说，介意我打个嗝吗，然后你就要，我们就要做了。你根本没。为什么还要说呢？是个虚假警报吗？
Because I didn't see you burp. Yeah. No, I came up. It was right on the, whatever this is part of your throat is, but it didn't. You are, you are, I will say, after having been on the road with you for 10 days, almost two weeks. I'm a burper. You're quite a burper.
因为我没看见你打嗝。对。不，它上来了。它就在，不管喉咙的哪个部位，但它没有。我得说，和你在一起在路上呆了10天，将近两个星期之后。我是个爱打嗝的人。你真的很会打嗝。
Yeah. Oh yeah. You are a loud burper like me. You like to, you like to. What? Yeah, no. You like to kind of yell your burp. Jason, you like to do the burp that's almost like is, you pretend as if you're about to
对，哦，是的。你和我一样是个声音很大的打嗝大王。你喜欢，你喜欢。什么？对，没有。你喜欢那种大喊大叫的打嗝。杰森，你喜欢那种几乎像是，你假装自己快要吐了的那种打嗝。
throw up. And you go, but I do the same thing. I do. I will say that to both of your credits, you, neither one of you have bubble problems from the other end. No, I don't have too many bubble problems from the other. Yeah. This guy's amazing.
然后你发出声音，但我也会做同样的事。我会的。我得对你们两个大加赞赏的是，你们两个都没有来自另一端的屁的问题。不，我没有太多来自另一端的屁的问题。对。这家伙太棒了。
Let's get, he, I don't want to waste time. He's received guys 16 Emmy nominations for one television show. Huh. Yeah. I'm going to say, yeah. I'm going to say, well, wait. So that's 16 years. Well no, it could be further.
我们来，他，我不想浪费时间。伙计们，他曾凭一部电视剧获得过16次艾美奖提名。哈。对。我要说，对。我要说，等等。所以那是16年。好吧，不，可能更多。
No, no. It could be multiple. Multiple. Yeah. Yeah, sure. He's one of the, he's one of the rares that's known for both comedy and drama and his films are some of the best ever made. This, I didn't know about him.
不，不。可能是多次。多次。对。没错。他是因喜剧和剧情都闻名的人中极少数的一位，他的电影是有史以来拍得最好的电影之一。这个，我之前不知道。
He returned to his high school in St. Louis, Missouri to teach eighth grade acting and one of his students was the Ellie Kemper. I didn't know that. Really? Because I loved this. And I hope we talk about it for the entire episode. He's an avid golfer. There's none other than the dashingly handsome, the talented, very relatable, John Hamm.
他回到他位于密苏里州圣路易斯的母校高中教八年级表演，他的学生之一就是埃利·肯珀（Ellie Kemper）。我不知道这个。真的吗？因为我太喜欢这个了。我希望我们整整一集都在谈论这个。他是个高尔夫狂热爱好者。他正是那位风度翩翩、才华横溢、极具亲和力的乔恩·哈姆。
What? What? What? Did I get any of that right, John? Yeah, you got it all right. I did really. Him. You have to say, I don't think I've ever been immediately put in a good mood from any of
什么？什么？什么，乔恩？我哪怕说对了一点吗？对，你全说对了。我真的猜中了。他。你必须得说，我觉得我从来没有像这样被我们之前的任何一个嘉宾瞬间逗开心过。
our previous guests. I know. It was a pretty low bar given the fart burp conversation that I stumbled onto. Yeah. Do you want to join in? You just perked me up. Hi boys. John.
我知道。考虑到我刚才无意中闯入的放屁和打嗝对话，这标准确实挺低的。对。你想加入进来吗？你刚才让我精神一振。嗨，伙计们。乔恩。
What's happening, Ham? It's been a minute. How are you doing? Oh, John. The best or nothing? Yes. Exactly. We got three car guys on here.
怎么了，哈姆？好久不见。你最近怎么样？哦，乔恩。要么最好，要么不做？对。没错。我们这里有三个爱车之人。
Come on, John. Get a fucking car contract. Or how about a motorcycle, John? Let me hear you sell a Yamaha right now. Okay, ready? Hey, guys. Are you in a hurry? Get a Yamaha.
得了吧，乔恩。去签个该死的汽车合同吧。或者弄辆摩托车怎么样，乔恩？让我听听你现在怎么推销雅马哈。好吧，准备好了吗？嘿，伙计们。你在赶时间吗？买辆雅马哈。
Wait. You're advocating. They're going to be like, no, no, no. We don't want to advocate for people to speed if you're in a hurry. Hey, guys. Pissed off at those dudes cutting line by going right in between your cars. Get a Yamaha. Hey, guys.
等等。你在作主张。他们会觉得，不，不，不。如果你赶时间，我们可不主张大家超速。嘿，伙计们。对那些从你们车流中间直接超车加塞的家伙很不爽吗？买辆雅马哈。嘿，伙计们。
Why don't we've in and out of traffic? Hey, we make musical instruments and motorcycles. That's not weird. Hey, you can play our car. Do you want to ride up to your baby grand in style? Hey, I wonder how many products Yamaha makes. They make musical instruments. They make pianos, obviously.
为什么我们不在车流中左穿右插呢？嘿，我们既制造乐器又制造摩托车。这可不奇怪。嘿，你可以弹我们的车。你想风风光光地骑到你的平台三角钢琴前吗？嘿，我很好奇雅马哈制造了多少产品。他们制造乐器。他们当然制造钢琴。
Yes. They make guitars. I know they make violins because I had one in third grade. Really? A Yamaha violin? I believe I did. Whoa. How long did you play violin?
是的。他们制造吉他。我知道他们制造小提琴，因为我三年级时有一把。真的吗？雅马哈的小提琴？我想我是有的。哇。你拉了多久小提琴？
I think until about sixth grade. And then it just got too, I could never really read music. Yeah. It got too complicated. I just, I could still kind of do it from memory, like that weird long, long-term memory where you remember lyrics of songs, but like, you know, your mom's birthday somehow. You forget. It's the weirdest thing how your brain-
我想大概到六年级吧。然后它变得太，我从来没真正看懂过谱子。对。变得太复杂了。我只是，我仍然能凭记忆拉一点，就像那种奇怪的长期记忆，你记得歌曲的歌词，但像，你知道的，你妈妈的生日，你不知怎么就忘了。大脑这东西真是太奇怪了——
What's your mom's birthday? February 1st. Oh, well, that's a good one. Who would forget that? It's a good one. That's a very easy day. Did you move on to a different instrument, or did you just say screw it? No.
你妈妈的生日是什么时候？2月1日。哦，那是个好日子。谁会忘呢？这是个好日子。那是一个非常容易记住的日子。你转去学别的乐器了，还是就此算了吧？不。
I think that's when, like, sports became kind of paramount, and I just did that. Would you jump into in sports? Football, baseball, swimming, soccer, basketball, what have you? It was a- Were you kind of good at all of them? I was better at football, baseball, but I was kind of good at a lot of stuff. This is the high school I went to. He says, borough's baseball.
我想那是体育变得至关重要的时候，我就只搞那个了。你在体育方面都玩些什么？美式橄榄球、棒球、游泳、英式足球、篮球，诸如此类？这是一个——你这些都很擅长吗？我更擅长橄榄球和棒球，但我对很多运动都挺在行的。这是我读的高中。他说，巴勒斯（Burroughs）棒球。
This was my baseball shirt from 10th grade. Is that your actual 10th grade t-shirt? Yeah. Yeah. Congratulations. What brand is that? That's really holding up. I think it's a champion.
这是我十年级的棒球衫。这是你十年代的真实T恤吗？对。对。祝贺你。这是什么牌子的？质量真好。我觉得是冠军牌（Champion）。
Will's high school t-shirt's now a beautiful mid-drift that he wears every once in a while. It's turned into an homage to 90s Britney Spears. Jason's high school t-shirt is a Winterbrothers lot tour shirt. It's a tank. Okay. It's got a cap to match it. It's from up front. They came in after Al.
威尔的高中T恤现在成了一件漂亮的露脐装，他每隔一段时间就会穿一次。它已经变成了对90年代小甜甜布兰妮的致敬。杰森的高中T恤是一件感恩而死乐队（Grateful Dead）巡演T恤。这是一件背心。好吧。它还有一顶与之匹配的帽子。这是前台乐队的。他们是在阿尔之后来的。
It's from up front. 1988 up front. I didn't know that about high school where you graduated with an English degree and then went back to your high school to teach it because that's kind of like a- I'm one of the few people that loved high school and clearly you did too. I went to a really excellent high school. The aforementioned John Burroughs High School in St. Louis, Missouri and we had like crazy, we were encouraged to try everything so it was like arts and sports and academics and
这是前台乐队的。1988年的前台。我不知道你高中时获得了英语学位，然后又回高中去教书的事，因为这有点像——我是少数几个热爱高中生活的人之一，显然你也一样。我读了一所非常棒的高中。前面提到的位于密苏里州圣路易斯的约翰·巴勒斯高中，我们有那种疯狂的经历，我们被鼓励去尝试一切，所以就像艺术、体育和学术，
everybody was sort of encouraged to achieve and do well and that sort of was the ethos of the whole joint. So you didn't have to be good at it but you had to try and that was the fun of it all and exposing, getting exposed to like all of these different disciplines was really, was really cool. And it wasn't, you know, there weren't like the jocks and the nerds and the sportos or whatever the Edie McClurg thing from Ferris Bueller is of all of the gradations. They were all kind of-
每个人都在某种程度上被鼓励去取得成就并做得很好，这正是整个学校的精神风貌。所以你不必样样精通，但你必须去尝试，这才是其中的乐趣所在，而且接触、去接触所有这些不同的学科真的，真的很酷。而且并不是，你知道，没有什么运动员、书呆子、运动健将或者《春天不是读书天》里埃迪·麦克利格（Edie McClurg）那种等级划分。大家都有点——
Nice call on Edie McClurg. Come on. You got to know McClurg. You got to have McClurg at the top of that. I did. I did a show with her for five years. Did you really? With that woman.
对埃迪·麦克利格的评价真准。拜托。你得了解麦克利格。你得把麦克利格排在第一位。我是。我和她一起拍了五年节目。真的吗？跟那个女人。
Yeah. Hey, so, but now John, don't be falsely modest here but I've got you between the jocks and the nerds, I've got you heavier over on the jock side. Yeah. The dials twisted a little to that side for sure. Very well in high school. Is that, was that a fair statement? Yeah.
对。嘿，所以，但是现在，乔恩，在这里别假谦虚了，我在运动员和书呆子之间权衡，我觉得你更倾向于运动员那边。对。指针确实有点偏向那一边。高中时表现很好。这是，这是一个公平的评价吗？对。
I graduated with honors and yeah. That's not what I'm talking about. Yeah. Yeah it is. You did okay? Did you do all right? Yeah. Okay.
我毕业时获得了荣誉学位，而且，是的。我说的可不是这个。对。没错，就是这个。你过得挺好？你干得不错？对。好吧。
Why do you keep winking at him? I'm not winking. Did you, look, we're talking about sports. Did you score? Did you score a lot? I scored a lot of points. Yeah. I scored a lot of points.
你为什么一直对她眨眼？我没眨眼。你看，我们在谈论体育。你得分了吗？你得了很多分吗？我得了不少分。对。我得了不少分。
I played a lot of defense. Did you put a lot in the bucket? That's how good he was. Did you put a lot in the basket? I don't know where this metaphor is going. Jason, is Amanda got you like on a no fly list? What's going on right now? Are you not?
我防守表现很多。你投进了很多球吗？他就是这么厉害。你投进了很多篮吗？我不知道这个隐喻要往哪里去了。杰森，阿曼达（Amanda）是不是把你列入禁飞名单了？现在是怎么回事？你是不是？
What's going on? Well then how did, all right, so then, so then you start to feather in. Jason, fix your hair. I'm sorry. You start to feather in some theater, right? Did that, did that? Feather. Feather in some theater.
怎么回事？好吧，那你是怎么，好吧，那么，那么你开始融入。杰森，整理一下你的头发。我很抱歉。你开始融入一些戏剧表演，对吧？那，那是？融入。融入一些戏剧。
Feather in some, and then did you braid anything in? I don't have a lot of terms. Will's so tired of my shit. I love it. But it's new to John. So be, be hush hush. There was, there was some theater feathering for sure. Yeah, did the jocks ostracize you for that?
融入一些，然后你编了什么进去吗？我没有那么多术语。威尔太厌烦我的废话了。我喜欢这样。但这对乔恩来说是新鲜的。所以大家安静，安静。确实有一些戏剧成分的融入。对。运动员们为此排挤你吗？
That's a new one. Well, I'm going to, I'm going to feather that one in. Did they ostracize you and then did the nerds embrace and receive you? Like I said, no, not really, because there was a real blend of, talk about feathering. We were, both groups were feathered together quite well. Yeah. And the jocks were all over. We did the senior production, senior year production was Godspell.
这是一个新词。好吧，我要，我要把它融入进去。他们排挤你，然后书呆子们张开双臂接纳了你？就像我说的，不，并没有，因为有一种真正的融合，说到融入。我们，这两个群体完美地融合在一起。对。而且运动员们到处都是。我们的毕业演出，毕业那一年的演出是《福音》（Godspell）。
So as in most high school productions, they were, you know, 35 roles and they've split up roles and you would, you would do half a song and with the exception of me who played Judas and the kid who played Jesus. So yeah, you know, it was, it was fun and exciting and it was, you know, something to do and it just, it was encouraged. So we all did it. It was fun. If I looked at your high school picture, did you have a luxurious hair?
所以就像大多数高中演出一样，有，你知道，35个角色，他们把角色分摊，你会，你会演半首歌，除了我扮演犹大和那个扮演耶稣的孩子。所以，你知道，这很有趣，也很令人兴奋，而且，你知道，有事情可做，而且受到学校鼓励。所以我们都参与了。这很有趣。如果我看你的高中毕业照，你当时有一头奢华的头发吗？
I had a good flow in 89. Real good flow. Real salad, huh? Bateman-esque, I would say. Jason, this is, I think Ham's giving you a run for your money, he's got a great flow. He can have it. John wins every category with any man on the planet, you know, your foolish, you just chase the silver with him.
89年时我有一头很好的飘逸长发。真的很好的飘逸发型。发型很棒，对吧？可以说是贝特曼式的（Bateman-esque）。杰森，这个，我觉得哈姆要在发型上给你点颜色看看了，他有一头超棒的飘逸长发。他尽管拿去好了。乔恩在地球上的任何一个男人中都在所有类别中获胜，你知道的，你太傻了，你居然想跟他比发色。
Listen, it's just nice to be nominated in any category. Wait, Johnny, when you went back to teach at your high school, was there anybody still there that you knew? Oh yeah. There was tons of teachers that I knew and loved. So it was kind of a trip. Now teaching behind, beside them? Yeah.
听着，能被提名任何奖项就已经是件好事了。等等，约翰尼，当你回到你的高中教书时，那里还有你认识的人吗？哦，是的。有成吨我认识并且喜爱的老师。所以这真是一次奇妙的经历。现在和他们并肩教书？对。
Yeah. There were now colleagues, which is really cool. That's crazy. And in fact, the guy who was, who was pretty much responsible for me becoming a professional actor, giving me the encouragement and hiring me and got me my equity card eventually. Wow. I kind of taught under him as his, that was my pitch was like, look, you're so, such a good teacher that you, you made this department like a fun thing to do.
对。他们现在是同事了，这真的很酷。这太疯狂了。事实上，那个，差不多可以说是他让我成为了一名职业演员，给我鼓励、雇用我并最终帮我拿到演员工会卡（equity card）的人。哇。我有点像在他的手下教书，作为他的助教，我的推销词是：听着，你太，你是一位如此优秀的老师，你把这个部门搞得这么有趣。
You have way too many students. So you need a, you need a helper. And basically I'll be the like junior theater teacher if you'll have me and they did. And when was that? I graduated college in 93. So this would have been 94, 94, 95. And then I moved to LA in 95. I did too.
你的学生实在太多了。所以你需要一个，你需要一个助手。基本上如果你不介意的话，我来当那个初级戏剧老师，他们同意了。那是什么时候？我1993年大学毕业。所以这大概是94年，94、95年。然后我在95年搬到了洛杉矶。我也是。
Okay. Wow. What a coincidence. Okay. Lower your eyebrows. Sean. A lot of people hit the airport in 95 out here. Like a million a day.
好的。哇。真是巧合。好吧。把你的眉毛放下来。肖恩。95年有很多涌向这儿的机场。每天大约有一百万。
I remember we auditioned up against each other all the time, Sean, so it was, all the time. Wait a minute. I lost another one down here. And then I went on the 405. I was on the 405, Bill. What car? What exit did you go on? Cause I was on the 405.
我记得我们以前总是一起去试镜，肖恩，所以是，一直都在试镜。等等。我又在这里错过了一个。然后我上了405号公路。我在405号公路上，比尔。你走的哪个出口？因为我在405号公路上。
Okay, wait. I came here so long ago was the 404. Thank you. Hello. Hello. It's so sleepy. Okay. Wait a minute.
好吧，等等。我来这儿太久了，那时还是404号。谢谢。你好。你好。太困了。好的。等等。
Sorry, John, when we were on tour, Will or Jason, one of them came up. It was Will. The best pun in the history of puns. Stupid. It was the dumbest. You were eating Japanese food. I kept going. I was too lazy to make, to make dinner, so I ordered some, some Japanese food.
抱歉，乔恩，当我们巡演时，威尔或杰森，他们中的一个人提出了一个梗。是威尔。双关语历史上最好的双关语。太蠢了。这是最无聊的。你们当时在吃日本料理。我一直在说。我懒得做晚饭，所以我点了一些，一些日本料理。
Sashimi. It's so stupid, and we were so punch drunk and tired, we couldn't stop laughing. Oh God, it was that funny. I was crying real tears. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show. John, would you ever consider doing something so generous and loving and give back-ish as going, as teaching the eighth grade class again, now that you're, that you got the 16
生鱼片。太蠢了，我们当时累得脑子都不转了，笑得停不下来。哦天哪，有那么好笑吗。我都笑出真眼泪了。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。乔恩，你有没有考虑过做一件如此慷慨、充满爱心且像回馈母校一样的事，比如再次去教八年级班，既然你现在已经有了16个——
Emmys, this incredible career. Nominations. Nominations. Nominations. That's crazy. Is that the most nominations anybody's ever received for one show? It's got to be a record. I don't think so.
艾美奖。提名。提名。提名。这太疯狂了。这是任何人凭一部剧获得的最多的提名吗？这绝对是个纪录。我不这么认为。
That's crazy. I think there's been, because they were kind of, they were for, eventually I became a producer on the show, so I got nominated for best show and things like that. But you won three as an actor? I won one. Oh. No. Yeah.
这太疯狂了。我想有过，因为它们是，最终我成了该剧的制片人，所以我获得了最佳剧集之类的提名。但你作为演员赢得了三个？我赢了一个。哦。不。对。
But I was nominated, I think, as a guest star on SNL and on 30 Rock and a couple of things like that. So I think those have been lumped in there. What'd you do with all the speeches? Would you do with the 15 speeches that you didn't use? I still got them. I bet you do. Right?
但我被提名过，我想，是作为《周六夜现场》和《我为喜剧狂》以及其他一些节目的客串明星。所以我想那些都被归到一起了。你拿那些没用上的15篇获奖感言怎么办？我一直留着呢。我敢打赌你留着。对吧？
I still got them right up here. No, no. Did you memorize them or did you write them down? No, no. I didn't write anything. I never wrote anything down ever. You didn't have any sort of thoughts prepared? If I get up there, I want to make sure I don't forget to thank-
我一直把它们记在这儿呢。不，不。你是把它们背下来了还是写下来了？不，不。我什么都没写。我从来没写过任何东西。你没有什么准备好的想法吗？如果我上台，我要确保我不会忘记感谢——
Honestly, no. I really didn't. Did you, Jason, did you write a few of the times that you lost? Oh, yeah. No, I've got a book. Yeah. You did write them down? Yeah.
老实说，没有。我真的没有。杰森，你写过几次你落选时的感言吗？哦，对。不，我有一本书。对。你确实写下来了？对。
I was an early adopter for when Bateman won. I was right there on, I've probably numbered four on the text chain. Congrats, buddy. John is incredibly- Reserve it. Supportive. Love you. Consistent.
当贝特曼获奖时，我是最早的拥护者之一。我就在那里，在群聊里我大概排第四。恭喜，老兄。乔恩非常——保持理智。支持大家。爱你们。始终如一。
Oh, fuck. You know what? Yes, a good point. Congrats, Jason. What happened? I know it's been a couple of years. No, you're winning the Emmy. Sorry, I don't think I ever said anything.
哦，操。你知道吗？是的，说得好。恭喜，杰森。怎么了？我知道已经过去好几年了。不，你要赢得艾美奖了。抱歉，我觉得我从来没说什么。
Hey, better late than that. Wait. It's a shame, man. It's a shame, man. It's a shame. It's a dollar. You know what? Will can use the same joke again, another one from the tour, which was when I said to
嘿，总比没有好。等等。真丢脸，伙计。真丢脸，伙计。真丢脸。才一块钱。你知道吗？威尔可以再次使用那个笑话，巡演时的另一个笑话，也就是当我对——
Jason, I got him golf balls for Christmas, like two sets of 18 golf balls each or something. And I said, did you ever get that? And he goes, yeah, I already had those. And Will goes, that's a twist on thank you. Wait. What did I say? I already had those. No, Sean, you said that you dropped them, Sean, you go, I gave you like a couple of
杰森说，我圣诞节送了他高尔夫球，比如两盒每盒18个的高尔夫球什么的。我说，你收到那个了吗？他说，对，我本来就有了。威尔说，这是对“谢谢”的一种独特的反转。等等。我说什么了？我本来就有了。不，肖恩，你说你把它们弄丢了，肖恩，你说，我给了你几盒高尔夫球。
boxes of golf balls. You came over to my house and I gave them to you and go, and Jason, you said, oh, yeah, yeah, I did get those. I said, well, that's a fun twist on thank you. That's pronounced. Thank you. That's pronounced. Thank you.
你来到我家，我把它们给了你，然后你说，哦，对，对，我确实收到了那些。我说，嗯，这是对“谢谢”的一种搞笑反转。这叫作。谢谢。这叫作。谢谢。
I don't think that happened. I don't. I think you're both. Way back to Jason's question, would you ever go back and teach now, John? Would you ever? Does that desire still there? I sure would. I was offered a chance to extend my contract by another year and I would have loved to
我觉得那没发生。我不觉得。我觉得你们俩。回到杰森的问题，乔恩，你现在还会回去教书吗？你还会吗？那种渴望还在吗？我当然会。当时有人提供机会让我把合同延长一年，我本很乐意——
have done it, but I was 24 turning 25 at the time and I thought, well, maybe I'm at least going to try to do LAC what happens and, you know, I did. And I really would though, I found it tremendously fulfilling. I don't know what teaching is like now with phones and internet. This was pre-internet, pre-phone. Well, that's how I was going to kind of ask, like, what teaching would be like now for you though? Like, you as an acting teacher then versus how you would teach acting now, not to get
那么做的，但我当时24岁，快要25岁了，我想，好吧，也许我至少应该尝试去洛杉矶看看会发生什么，你知道的，我真的去了。而且我真的很想去，我发现那份工作极其充实。我不知道现在有了手机和互联网，教学会是什么样。那是互联网和手机出现之前的年代。嗯，我本来想问的就是，对你来说现在的教学会是什么样的？比如，你作为当时的表演老师与你现在会怎么教表演相比，为了不陷入表演的细枝末节而失去我们仅有的一个听众。但就像你关于表演的整个理论一样，你现在会怎么教孩子们？会有所不同吗？
into acting weeds because we'll lose our one listener. But like, as your whole theory about acting, like, how would you teach the kids now? Would it be different? It would probably be similar, if not identical. I would just have much more credibility as a 50-year-old rather than a 24-year-old guy trying to wear a tie. What was the gig that you had, what was the job you had right before, Madman? I was kind of unemployed for like, I got a pilot, which I got fired off of.
可能会相似，甚至一模一样。我只是作为一个50岁的人，会比当年那个试图系领带的24岁小伙子更有可信度。你在《广告狂人》之前接的那个差事，你做的工作是什么？我有一段时间处于失业状态，比如，我接了一个试播集，然后被炒了。
And then I tested for seven other pilots the following pilot season and got none. I could went all, you know, all the way up to the top and then- Seven times. Oh my God. So Madman was that my eighth test that season and it was crazy late in what used to be called pilot season because it was on AMC, which didn't really know how to do pilot season. So they just had a different schedule than everybody else. But I had tested seven times and then biffed them all.
然后在随后的试播集季里，我又去为另外七个试播集试镜，结果一个都没拿到。我一路过关斩将，你知道的，一路杀到最后，然后——七次。天哪。所以《广告狂人》是我那个赛季的第八次试镜，而且时间晚得离谱，在以前被称为试播集季的时候，因为它是在AMC电视台播出的，他们其实并不懂得怎么搞试播集季。所以他们的日程安排和别人不一样。但我试镜了七次，然后全搞砸了。
So yeah, so my last job was a pilot that was called something that then went on to be called a show called Related with Lizzie Kaplan, Jennifer Esposito, and oh yeah, someone else. And I played the love interest of God, why am I spacing on her name? She was in Pretty Woman with Julia Roberts. San Jacomo? Yes, Laura San Jacomo. So Laura San Jacomo was the eldest of three siblings and I was her love interest and she killed herself on this pilot.
所以，是的，我最后的工作是一个试播集，它的名字后来变成了一部名为《关系》（Related）的剧，由丽兹·卡潘（Lizzy Kaplan）、詹妮弗·埃斯波西托（Jennifer Esposito）还有，哦对了，另外一个人主演。我扮演上帝的爱慕对象，天哪，为什么我想不起她的名字了？她曾和朱莉娅·罗伯茨一起演过《风月俏佳人》。劳拉·圣贾科莫（Laura San Jacomo）？对，劳拉·圣贾科莫。所以劳拉·圣贾科莫是三个兄弟姐妹中的老大，我是她的爱慕对象，她在试播集里自杀了。
She was wonderful in it and they forced her call every day and she had a kid at home. It was like, they treated her terribly. And then they fired her and the powers that be said, you're out. And they told me they're like, but you're, we like you and you're going to stay. I was like, there's no part for like, that was my love interest. I don't have a person and I'm not in the family. So it doesn't make sense. No, no, no, no, no.
她在剧里表现得很棒，他们每天都强迫她随叫随到，而她家里还有一个孩子。就像是，他们对她太恶劣了。然后他们解雇了她，掌权者说，你出局了。他们对我说，但是你，我们喜欢你，你要留下来。我说，没有这样的角色啊，那可是我的爱慕对象。我没有搭档，我也不属于这个家庭。所以这说不通。不，不，不，不，不。
And they kept me, kept me, kept me. And I had to turn down another couple of jobs that now I was available for. And then they, they released my option on the last day and fired me. So that was, that was my last gig before Madame. That's so great. And what a, what a, what a change of perspective you have now on the other end of it. And we all know we've been there of just, just, just hearing you describe it brings almost like PTSD.
但他们还是把我留下了，留下了，留下了。我不得不拒绝了其他几份我本来有资格接的工作。然后他们在最后一天解除了我的合同选项，把我给炒了。所以，那就是我在《广告狂人》之前的最后一份工作。太棒了。而现在，当你走到事情的另一端时，你的视角发生了多么巨大的变化。我们都知道我们也曾经历过那种阶段，仅仅是听你描述它就几乎带来了创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。
Oh yeah. For sure. Yeah. Like you said, we've all, we've all had a version of that. Yeah. For sure. Oh, this is going to go. Oh, it didn't.
哦，是的。肯定的。对。就像你说的，我们所有人，我们都经历过那种版本的遭遇。对。肯定的。哦，这下要糟了。哦，并没有。
And then it's going to go in the far worst way, if we're possibly good at. Right. And a good example of while it probably felt like hell at the time had that show kept going, had they not fired you, you, you would have been unavailable to do Mad Men. So it was a great. Everything happens. Yeah. Everything happens for a reason.
然后事情会朝着最糟糕的方向发展，如果我们有哪怕一点点能力的话。没错。一个很好的例子是，虽然当时感觉就像在地狱一样，但如果那部剧继续拍下去，如果他们没有解雇你，你，你就无法出演《广告狂人》了。所以这是一件好事。一切皆有定数。对。一切发生都有它的原因。
So you're saying look at the bright side of things, which I, you know, I'm going to say, I agree with it. There's plenty of fluid in that glass, Johnny, I read somewhere that you, after Mad Men, you got offered like 800 parts where it took place in the 60s or some kind of same thing over and over and over and over again, but you were smart enough to wait out, wait for that one good thing. And what was that one thing? Well, there, there was obviously like, as soon as one thing hits, then there's five versions
所以你是说要看到事物光明的一面，对此，我（你知道的）表示赞同。那个杯子里装满了水，约翰尼，我 irgendwo 读到过，在《广告狂人》之后，你收到了大概800个发生在60年代的角色邀请，或者某种一遍又一遍重复的相同类型，但你足够聪明，懂得等待，等待那个好机会。那个好机会是什么？嗯，当然，显而易见的是，一旦某样东西火了，就会有五个类似的版本接踵而至。
of that thing that come around the pike. And so for us, it was NBC came out with something like called like pan AM something that was about like sexy stewardesses in the 60s. And then like there was some other version of like Woodstock and it was just all this stuff. And, and, you know, then the, like the movie Revolution Road came out, like there were all of these kinds of things that the 60s became kind of a hot commodity, or at least the late 60s.
所以对我们来说，NBC推出了诸如《泛美航空》（Pan AM）之类讲述60年代性感空姐的剧。然后还有关于伍德斯托克的其他版本，全都是这类的东西。而且，你知道，接着像电影《革命之路》（Revolution Road）也上映了，所有这些都让60年代变成了一个热门题材，或者至少是60年代末。
And, and it was, and not only that, it was just, yeah, it was like, so if there was a brooding dark character that smoke and drank a lot, then I got that script. And I was kind of like, that's my day job. Like I don't, and I, and I love it. And I get to do it at a very high level and I very much appreciate it, but it's my day job. Like I would rather do something radically different. Is any part of you like, Oh God, I, you know, I know what it's like to not work so much
而且不仅如此，是的，所以如果有一个抽烟喝酒很多的深沉黑暗角色，我就会拿到那个剧本。而我当时的想法是，那是我的日间工作。我不想，而且我，我喜欢它。我能以非常高的水准去完成它，我也非常感激，但这是我的日间工作。我宁愿做一些截然不同的事情。你有没有哪怕一点点觉得，哦天哪，我，你知道，我知道没那么多工作是什么滋味，也许我应该接下其中一个角色？就像，当你遇到这种情况时，本能反应往往是双手抓住一切，死死抓住不放。
that maybe I should just take one of these things. Like the, the immediate instinct when you have that is to just grab everything with both hands and hold on for dear life. But I don't know, there was something, I guess I was older. I was 36 at the time, 37, like I was kind of like, all right, I got this, this seems to be going really well. But then like, you know, Lord Michaels came calling and said, like, why don't you host the show?
但不知道为什么，我猜我当时年纪更大了。我当时36岁，37岁，就像是，好吧，我懂了，这似乎进展得很顺利。但随后，你知道的，洛恩·迈克尔斯（Lorne Michaels）打电话来，说，你为什么不来主持这个节目呢？
And I was literally like, this has to be a prank. I don't understand. And I, yes, yes. And in fact, I had to turn it down the first time he asked because my then girlfriend at the time and I were, had planned this huge trip. Like I'd never been to Greece. We had like, had planned this whole like two week long getaway and it was like, we couldn't, we couldn't move it.
我当时简直觉得：这肯定是个恶作剧。我无法理解。然后，是的，是的。事实上，他第一次邀请我时我不得不拒绝，因为我和当时的女友计划了一次超级大旅行。我从来没去过希腊。我们计划了整个两周的度假，而且根本无法，无法改期。
Wow. And I was like, well, I get to say no to Lord Michaels. Sean will never go to me, can I say again, tell him what happened? I got Sean. What happened, Sean? Oh, Jesus. Yeah. You can't help me too well.
哇。我想，好吧，我竟然对洛恩·迈克尔斯说“不”。肖恩绝对不会去找我，我能再讲一遍吗，告诉他发生了什么？我抓到肖恩了。怎么了，肖恩？哦，天哪。对。你可帮不了我太多。
I love the highlights. John, you know, it's funny, Mad Men was and remains such an incredibly, like it's one of those shows that really changed. I feel like in a lot of ways changed TV, changed the way that people look at TV was one of incredible, incredible writing and you were so incredible in it. And I'll tell you, here's a testament to how great you are. You were in that part and you are, cause it still lives on. When I actually started watching it in earnest, I had already known you a few years and then
我喜欢这些亮点。乔恩，你知道的，有趣的是，《广告狂人》过去是、现在也依然是一部如此不可思议的剧，它真的是那种改变了——我觉得在很多方面改变了电视行业，改变了人们看待电视的方式，它拥有不可思议的精彩剧本，你在里面的表现也极其出色。我跟你说，这就是你有多棒的证明。你出演了那个角色，而且你，因为这部剧至今仍然历久弥新。当我真正开始认真观看这部剧时，我已经认识你几年了，然后开始观看，完全沉浸其中，怎么看都不够，一集不落地一直看完全剧，老实说，你的表演真的深深打动了我，饰演唐·德雷珀（Don Draper）的你，真的，真的，真的非常了不起。它现在已经成历史了。绝对的。
started watching it and was completely immersed in it and could not get enough of it and watched absolutely every episode all the way through to the end and was really profoundly moved by your performance as Don Draper, honestly, and really, really, really truly and. It's historical now. Absolutely. Did it change the way you acted around John when you, when you need to, when you hang out with them afterwards? No, no, sure.
这有没有改变你在现实中对待乔恩的方式，当你，当你需要的时候，当你事后跟他一起玩的时候？不，不，当然没有。
No, but yes, of course, but, but, but I think. Way more deferential. Way more. Right. Let's see what John has to say. I don't know. He's my friend. My friend John.
不，但是是的，当然，不过，不过，我觉得。更加毕恭毕敬了。恭敬得多。没错。来看看乔恩怎么说。我不知道。他是我朋友。我的朋友乔恩。
My friend John is. John, do you want anything? I mean, that wasn't going out, but I will. I will totally go out. The kids are in bed and the doors are locked, but I'll get up. No, I'll get dressed. I'll get dressed. But, but did.
我的朋友乔恩是。乔恩，你想来点什么吗？我的意思是，本来没打算出门，但我会去的。我完全愿意出门。孩子们已经上床睡觉了，门也锁上了，但我会起床的。不，我会穿好衣服。我会穿好衣服。但是，但是。
So you do something like that. That changes your life in, you know, so many ways. Absolutely. And it's at first scary probably and weird. Like you say, Lord Michaels is calling you and like. And you, and it didn't happen at 18 years old. Yeah. I, I to this day, you know, Jason God, I do be your life and growing up the way you grew
所以你做了那样的事。那在那么多方面改变了你的生活。绝对的。一开始这可能既可怕又诡异。就像你说的，洛恩·迈克尔斯打电话给你，而且——而且这并非发生在你18岁的时候。是的，我至今仍，你知道的，杰森，天哪，我看着你的人生以及你成长的经历，你从六岁起就出名了。
up being famous since you were six. I remember you on Silver Spoons. I'll say it. Yeah. And I was a fan. I was a fan early on. I was like, this kid's good. I get it.
我还记得你在《银匙》（Silver Spoons）里的表现。我就直说了。对。我当时就是个粉丝。我很早就成了粉丝。我当时想，这小子真不错。我懂的。
Um, but, uh, yeah, it changes everything, you know, and it, and it really does provide an incredible amount of opportunity, but it comes with an incredible amount of like, you know, uh, caveat, you know, like just be careful what you wish for in a lot of ways. So, you know, we also, we also came around, you know, the show really kind of got famous. And I then got famous around 2007, which seems like not that long ago, but was a long time ago. Not only it was 15 years ago, but it was, um, that was the year they came out with the iPhone.
嗯，但是，是的，这改变了一切，你知道的，它确实带来了不可思议的大量机会，但它也伴随着不可思议的大量，你知道的，警告，你知道的，在很多方面就是当心你许下的愿望。所以，你知道的，我们也是，我们也是在，你知道的，这部剧真正开始出名的时候遇到了这个。然后我在2007年左右开始出名，这听起来好像没那么久以前，但其实是很久以前了。不仅是因为那是15年前，而且那是，那是他们推出iPhone的那一年。
And I think it was maybe around the time that Twitter started. And then like 2010 was Instagram and like all of these things were starting to kind of like people's access to the internet became in their pocket and 24 seven. And so that was kind of the blogging recap culture was just starting. So this idea of kind of actively engaged fans that could in real time kind of talk about the shows really came around right when we happened to get famous. So there was a lot of like serendipity and luck involved in, in our shows success. And it was, you know, it was crazy and it was a whirlwind and it was impossible to kind
我想大概也是推特（Twitter）刚出现的时候。然后大约在2010年有了Instagram，所有这些东西开始纷纷涌现，人们获取互联网的途径变成了装在口袋里、全天候24小时随身携带。所以那正是博客和复盘文化刚刚起步的时候。因此，这种积极参与的粉丝群体能够在实时讨论节目的想法，恰好在我们碰巧成名的时候出现了。所以我们的剧能成功，其中包含了很多偶然性和运气。而且，你知道的，这太疯狂了，这是一场旋风，而且让人无法不去享受，因为真的很享受。而且这种情况极其罕见，你和我，我们都曾参与过至少一部——在某些情况下是好几部——这样的热门作品，你根本无法掌控，只能顺其自然。而这正是当时我所做的。但是，在你的这个年纪，能在某一行业获得这种程度的名誉、尊重和成功，我认为是极其幸运的，因为你已经具备了应对这种事情的应对机制。
of not enjoy because it was enjoyable. And it's so rarely happens that you and we all, we've all been a part of at least one in some, in some cases, several hits like that where you just, it's out of your control and you just have to hold on for the ride. And that's kind of what I did. But getting that level of fame and, and respect and success in, in, in a profession at, at the age you are at is, is fortuitous, I would think in that, in that you've, you've got the coping mechanisms to, to, to deal with something like that.
你能够从名气中汲取一些真正有益的部分，并以健康的方式将其融入你的生活吗？是的。我的意思是，我觉得其中的一部分，就是学会坦然接受并欣赏它。如果这说得通的话。对。对。我觉得人们往往想要贬低它、淡化它，并保持谦逊，这也是非常健康和极好的。
Were you able to take some really beneficial parts from fame and incorporate it into your life and in a healthy way? Yeah. I mean, I think part of it is, is being okay with, with appreciating it. If that makes any sense. Yeah. Yeah. I think that are want to like poo poo it and play it down and, and be modest with it,
但坦然说出“你知道吗？是的。我干得不错。万岁。太好了。我。我可不是白白奋斗了10年却几乎没有得到任何认可、赞誉、金钱或工作机会，你知道的，当我95年登陆洛杉矶时，我和肖恩在1995年登陆洛杉矶时。我花了三年时间才找到一份工作。所以，你知道的，这并非没有努力。我为所有事情试镜。你知道的，我奇怪的试镜故事是为咪咪·莱德（Mimi Leder）的《天地大冲撞》（Deep Impact）试镜，那个角色最终归了乔恩·费儒（Jon Favreau）。对。
which is, which is also very healthy and good. But there's, there's something very, I think healthy about saying like, you know what? Yeah. Good for me. Hooray. Yeah. Me. I, I didn't for nothing like work for 10 years with very little recognition or accolades
而且，你知道的，直到今天，我依然会说我对他还是有点生气的。当然，当然。他抢了我的机会。他当时有《摇摆者》（Swingers）。他是个编剧。他有那么多，他根本不需要《天地大冲撞》。
or money or jobs or anything like, you know, when I landed in 95, when Sean and I landed in 1995. He took me three years to even get a job. So, you know, it wasn't, and it wasn't for lack of trying. I auditioned for everything. You know, my, my weird audition story was auditioning for Mimi leader for deep impact, a part that eventually went to John Fabra. Yeah.
他本可以退让一步，把那个角色让给我的。我当时很需要它。不，但是。他现在可以报答你了。给你在《曼达洛人》（Mandalorian）里安排个好角色。一点《曼达洛人》的爱。对。一个精彩紧凑的三集客串弧光。
And, you know, who to this day, I still say I'm still a little angry at him. Sure. Sure. He beat me up for that. He had swingers. He had swingers. He's a writer. He had so much and he couldn't need deep impact.
而且，你知道的，直到今天，我仍然对他说我还是有点生他的气。当然，当然。他为此把我痛揍了一顿。他有摇摆人。他有摇摆人。他是个作家。他拥有那么多，却不需要《天地大冲撞》。
He couldn't back off and just give me that. I needed it. No, but. He could pay you back now. Give you some nice sweet arc on Mandalorian. Some Mandalorian love. Yeah. Nice little tight little three up, three up arc.
他无法退让一步，就把那个给我。我需要它。不，但是。他现在可以还给你了。在《曼达洛人》里给你一些甜蜜的弧光。一些《曼达洛人》的爱。是的。一个很好、很紧凑的三集弧光。
Well, he's also, he's the guy in all that stuff too. And all the Marvel stuff. Isn't he? Yeah. Johnny Marvel. Come on. The guy, isn't he in those movies too? He's down.
嗯，而且他，他也是所有那些片子里的人。还有所有的漫威电影，对吧？对。强尼·漫威。拜托。那家伙，他难道也演了那些电影吗？他很厉害。
He's down. He's a driver, right? Sure. Getting his sag benefits. You know what I mean? Listen, he's been, he's driven Robert Downey. Yeah. In the Iron Man trilogy.
他很厉害。他是个司机，对吧？当然。拿点演员工会的福利。你知道我的意思吗？听着，他当过，他给罗伯特·唐尼开过车。对。《钢铁侠》三部曲里。
Yeah. Quadruple. Yeah. He's driven Jack Nicholson. Yeah, I think. Truly? In as good as it gets. Really?
对。四部曲。对。他给杰克·尼科尔森开过车。对，我想是的。真的吗？在《尽善尽美》里。真的吗？
Am I making this up? I don't remember. Was he a driver in that? Was he in as good as it gets? I don't know. I'll be honest. I might be conflating a lot. I think you made that up.
我是胡编的吗？我不记得了。他在那里面是个司机吗？他演了《尽善尽美》吗？我不知道。老实说。我可能把很多事情搞混了。我觉得那是你瞎编的。
John is a fun guy to act with. Have you guys done that? No, but I obviously know him. He's a fun guy in general. He is. He is fun in a scene. Yeah. Very fast.
和约翰一起演戏很有趣。你们俩试过吗？没有，但我显然认识他。他总体来说是个很有趣的人。他是。他在戏里很有趣。对。反应极快。
And him and Vince together. That must have been fun to watch. Oh man. Yeah. I've met those guys. I live on the east side of LA. And they're kind of credited with kind of bringing Los Feliz into the hipster world for sure. Yeah.
还有他和文斯在一起。那画面一定很好看。天哪。对。我遇到过这些人。我住在洛杉矶东区。人们普遍认为他们把洛费利兹带入了嬉皮士的世界。没错。对。
Dresden. Dresden. The whole kind of swing, you know, swingers scene was their scene for sure. Right. And when those guys walked into a bar in 1996, like you knew it, it was. Oh yeah. They were very good hangs and they were very funny even then. And, you know, the proofs in the pudding, they both have very nice careers.
德累斯顿。德累斯顿。整个那种摇摆舞，你知道，摇摆舞圈子绝对是他们的地盘。对的。当这些人在1996年走进酒吧时，你一眼就能认出来，就是他们。噢，是的。他们特别好相处，而且即使在当时也非常搞笑。而且，你知道，事实胜于雄辩，他们俩都有非常棒的职业生涯。
We were talking the other day about Jason and we're talking about Vince about how fucking quick and funny he is. It's just no one better at what he's fucking unreal. Yeah. And nobody does what he does, which is a nice place to be. Yeah. And now a word from our sponsor. All right.
我们前几天还在讨论杰森，我们谈到文斯是多么他妈的机智和搞笑。简直没有人比他更厉害了，他他妈的太神了。对。而且没有人能像他那样，这可真是一个好位置。对。现在插播一条广告。好的。
Back to the show. John, when you, you know, now that you worked your butt off to get to where you are. And in hindsight, it probably took longer than you wanted and longer than what you explained before. Is there anything that you tell younger actors going through it now or any kind of business, businessy advice rather than acting, you know, technique advice that, you know, that you would probably pass on to anybody looking to make it now. You know, I've talked to actually Jenna Fisher about this, who's also from St. Louis, who
言归正传。约翰，当你在，你知道的，现在你付出了巨大的努力才有了今天的成就。事后看来，这可能比你想要的花了更长时间，也比你之前解释的要久。对于现在正在经历这一切的年轻演员，或者任何关于行业、业务方面的建议，而不是表演技巧方面的建议，你有什么想说的吗？你会把这些经验传授给任何现在想成功的人吗。你知道的，我其实跟珍娜·费舍尔聊过这个，她也是圣路易斯人，
I've known for some time. I didn't know her in St. Louis, but we were talking about something for some reason. And it's funny, like you can go to all of the acting schools in the world and nobody really teaches you about the business of acting. Right. And what it really is like, of course, like managing your day and managing your time and your expectations, your expectations for sure. Like thinking about, you know, here's what it is to like drive into the valley in August
我认识她有一段时间了。我不是在圣路易斯认识她的，但不知为什么我们在聊某件事。很有趣，就像你可以去世界上所有的表演学校，但没有人真正教你表演的商业运作。对。以及它真正的样子，当然，比如管理你的日程、管理你的时间以及你的期望，你的期望是肯定的。比如想想，你知道，这就是开着车在八月冲进山谷，
and then have another audition in Fox in an hour. You know, and it's, you know, it's a lot and it's real and it's actually the part of acting that most actors engage with from a professional standpoint, far more than they do, you know, scene study or whatever. And so there's that part. And there's also just the fact that everything at this level moves so quickly, especially in television, that if you're not ready to go, if you haven't done the work before you get to work, then you're, it's not going to go well.
然后一个小时后又要在福克斯参加另一个试镜。你知道，这，你知道的，这压力很大，而且很真实，实际上这是大多数演员从专业角度参与表演的部分，远比他们进行剧本研读或其他什么要多得多。所以有这部分原因。还有就是，在这个层面上的一切进展都太快了，尤其是在电视圈，如果你没有准备好开工，如果你在上工前没有做好功课，那么你，事情就不会顺利。
Right. For one reason or another. And I've seen it happen. I've been a victim of it of just like, oh, I'll just wing it. And then you're like, oh, right. But it's, it's a real lesson to learn of just, you know, it's the first one I learned in classes just like be prepared. I had, I had an acting teacher two years ago.
对。因为这样或那样的原因。我见过这种情况发生。我也曾是它的受害者，就觉得，哦，我随便应付一下就行了。然后你会发现，哦，原来如此。但这是一个需要吸取的真正教训，你知道的，这是我在课堂上学到的第一课，那就是：做好准备。我，我两年前有个表演老师。
He would, he kind of would, would, would profess this and he was kind of a working actor. He was a character, actor, guy and he'd lived in L.A. a long time. He had moved back to New York. It's like really nice. Charles Nelson Reilly or early nineties. Charles Bronson. He was Charles Bronson. It was the first film.
他会，他有点像会，会，会宣扬这一点，他算是一个还在接戏的演员。他是个性格演员，是个老油条，在洛杉矶住过很长时间。他又搬回了纽约。感觉真的很棒。查尔斯·纳尔逊·赖利，九十年代初。查尔斯·布朗森。他演过查尔斯·布朗森。那是第一部电影。
And we, we'd only, we'd only do scenes from Fort Apache, the Bronx, but, but he would. Great movie. He wasn't in that. Charles Bronson was. Sure he was. You had a lot to pick from, but I'm glad you picked that one. Me too. He would say the same thing, which, which was like as a young actor, if you get on, if
而且我们，我们只会，只会演《纽约大国民》（Fort Apache, the Bronx）里的片段，但是，但是他会。好电影。他没演那部。查尔斯·布朗森演了。他当然演了。你有太多选择余地了，但我很高兴你选了那个。我也是。他会说同样的话，那就是作为一个年轻演员，如果你上了，
you get to set and you start going like, I'm going to work through my stuff, you're fired. There's no time to work through your shit. They got to get this shot and they got to move on. And they don't give a fuck about what your process is and how you get there. You deliver when they fucking call action, be ready. And I think that that was like the, I had that in early age and I was, I felt lucky because I feel a lot of actors feel like I'm just going to go and I'm going to work it out. I'm going to feel it.
如果你到了片场，然后开始说“我要自己慢慢琢磨”，你被开除了。根本没有时间让你去琢磨你那些破事。他们得拍完这个镜头，然后还得赶下一个。他们才不管你的表演过程是什么样的，你是怎么酝酿情绪的。当他们他妈的喊“Action”的时候，你得交货，给老子准备好。我觉得这就是，我年轻的时候就懂这个，我觉得自己很幸运，因为我觉得很多演员都觉得“我到时候去了再说，我会临场发挥的，我会去感受的”。
Once they see how amazing I am, they'll give me all the time in the world. Right. But, but it depends on what you want. Right. If you want to be like, take Tom Cruise, for example, people are like, they didn't just go to him, like he, he worked his butt off to be Tom Cruise. You know what I mean? And having worked with him, he is the first guy on set.
“一旦他们看到我有多厉害，就会给我全世界所有的顶级时间。”对。但是，这取决于你想要什么。对。如果你想成为，以汤姆·克鲁斯为例，人们会说，他可不是轻而易举就得到了这一切，他付出了巨大的努力才成为了汤姆·克鲁斯。你知道我的意思吗？和共事过的人都知道，他是片场第一个到的人。
He were, you know, he's in the gym at five in the morning, call times at six, he's there. He's ready to go and he's the last guy that leaves. And it's that guy deserves it. You know, he wants it. He got it. He works hard at it. And that's, you know, Jason, I know you've directed. Have you guys both directed television?
他，你知道的，他早上五点就在健身房锻炼了，通告时间是六点，他就在那儿了。他随时准备开工，而且他是最后一个离开的人。所以这样的人实至名归。你知道的，他渴望成功。他得到了。他为此付出了巨大的努力。而且，你知道的，杰森，我知道你当过导演。你们俩都导演过电视剧吗？
Sean and Will, like it's the same thing when you sit through those auditions and you think all right, the guy that comes, who's going to come in and take this part? Right. He's going to come in. So I can worry about something else. So I can worry about something else. And by the way, so I can go back to the set. I got to shoot.
肖恩和威尔，就好像当你坐在那里听那些试镜时，你会想，好吧，谁会来接这个角色呢？对。他会走进来的。这样我就可以不用操心别的事了。这样我就可以不用操心别的事了。顺便说一句，这样我就可以回片场了。我还有镜头要拍。
Yeah. And, and you watch, and you watch the guys that do it, that walk in and just say like, I don't have any questions or, or I don't have any ridiculous questions. Hey, this is not 10 minutes of bullshit. No, it's like, let's do this. And I'm going to prove to you how, how I can crush this. And then it's like, great. That's the guy I want on the day when I'm 10 hours behind.
对。而且，而且你看，你看那些真正这么干的家伙，他们走进来就说，我没有任何问题，或者，我没有问什么荒谬的问题。嘿，这不是在扯淡十分钟。不，就像是，我们开始干吧。我要向你们证明我是怎么把这个角色演到极致的。然后就会觉得，太棒了。这就是我落后十小时进度时，最想在片场看到的人。
Sean, you do the, but you're, you haven't directed, but you also, you go to the, when it goes to the gym, you're the last guy there, the first guy out, right? Yeah. Very similar. Yeah. I mean, look at me. So John, growing up in St. Louis, did you, did you, did you spend any summers at the lake of the Ozarks down there?
肖恩，你做，但是你，你没有当过导演，但你也去，当说到去健身房时，你是最后一个离开，第一个到的，对吧？对。非常相似。对。我的意思是，看看我。所以，约翰，在圣路易斯长大的你，有没有，有没有，在那里的奥沙克湖度过什么夏天？
Yeah. In fact, my good portion of my family has retired down there. My, my, my dad's sister, my Betty lives, lives down there full time now. And my cousin, Is it true that there, that there's a bar down there that does real well called big dicks halfway in? No way. Is that a true story?
有。事实上，我的很大一部分家人都在那里退休了。我，我的，我爸的妹妹，我姑妈贝蒂现在常年住在那里。还有我的表弟，
It's entirely possible. If I'm, if I'm judging by the amount of, of, and the quality of puns that I've seen and heard throughout the years in the, in the lake of the Ozarks, the red neck. Is that true, Jason? Is that a real bar? That's a real bar from what I understand. And it is a very high level pun. That is, that they deserve to do a lot of business in that.
真的假的，那边有个酒吧生意特别火，叫“大鸟半程”（Big Dick's Halfway Inn）？没门。这是真事吗？
Jason, can we get, can we get a little something out of Marty Bird? I don't, I don't, I don't change at all. This is a full Marty right now. We hear a little something out of Marty Bird. This interview has been conducted by Marty Bird, I think. I'd love to have a conversation with Marty Bird real quick. I think it might go a little something like this. Now, did you ever see any, any, any money laundering or killings or anything down there?
完全有可能。如果我根据我在奥沙克湖多年来看过和听过的双关语的数量和质量来判断，那里的红脖子。真的吗，杰森？那是个真正的酒吧吗？据我所知，那是个真正的酒吧。而且这是一个水平极高的双关语。那是，他们值得在那儿做成大生意。
Very little, if any. We're painting a pretty bleak picture of the lake down there. There was a lot of bass fishing. Sure. A lot of water skiing. Yeah. And some pretty heavy, heavy drinking. Yeah.
杰森，我们能从马蒂·伯德身上学到点什么吗？我，我，我一点都没变。我现在就是个百分之百的马蒂。我们听听马蒂·伯德说点什么吗？这次采访是由马蒂·伯德主持的，我想。我很想和马蒂·伯德简短地聊一聊。我觉得对话可能会是这样的。话说回来，你在那边有没有看到过什么，洗钱啊、谋杀啊之类的事情？
But you know, a lot of, a lot of very poor water safety. Yeah. But you're not getting a murder a week down there. No. Yeah. We're taking a little license. You know, fall out of the boat, hit your head. Sure.
极少，如果有的话。我们把那边湖泊的景象描绘得有点凄凉了。那里有很多低音钓鱼。当然。有很多滑水活动。对。还有一些相当严重、相当严重的酗酒。对。
Son of a bitch. Yeah. I had my phone in my pocket. God damn it. A lot of that. For sure. A lot of anger with that. But not a lot of cartel guys walking down dirt roads with shotguns in the middle of the night, right?
但是你知道，有很多，很多非常糟糕的水上安全意识。对。但你在那边不会每周都发生谋杀案吧。没有。对。我们稍微艺术加工了一下。你知道，从船上掉下来，脑袋撞到。当然。
You just didn't see it. Yeah. And that doesn't mean it didn't exist. Now, are they upset at us for painting that type of a picture? I think any, any publicity for the Ozarks is good publicity at this point. You know, they do need to lengthen the runway there so they can get some commercial flights in there and really open up tourism, darn it. You're speaking, you're preaching the choir at this point. What you get down there and kind of ramrod something like that?
他妈的。对。我手机还在口袋里呢。真该死。有很多这种情况。绝对有。对此有很多愤怒。但不会有很多卡特尔分子在半夜拿着猎枪走在泥土路上，对吧？
Huh? Is that one of the other bars? The ramrod something like that? Ramrod does great business, but it's mostly on weekends. And it's gay. Mostly on weekends. Thank you. Johnny, what's your favorite best movie experience on a set or part that you played and experienced?
你根本看不到。对。但这并不意味着它不存在。那么，我们把那里的形象描绘成那样，他们生我们的气吗？我想，对于奥沙克湖来说，任何形式的宣传在这个时候都是好宣传。你知道，他们确实需要延长那里的跑道，这样才能有一些商业航班飞进去，真正打开旅游业的大门，该死的。你这是在，你这是在对牛弹琴啊。你在那边能插手并强行推行类似的事情吗？
I've got it right here. He's loaded with that one. I worked on a movie called Bad Times at the L Royale a couple years ago. Directed by a guy who, who I've known for a long time. He used to write promos for the WB. I auditioned to be the guy that reads the prom next on the WB. That guy that will probably got. No, I did CBS at that time.
哈？那是另一个酒吧吗？强行推行类似的东西？强行推行的生意非常好，但主要是在周末。而且是同性恋酒吧。主要在周末。谢谢。强尼，你在片场最喜欢的、最好的电影经历是什么？或者你扮演并经历过的角色？
Fair enough. Fair enough. And so, uh, and, and I, I got the offer for it, uh, during Sundance came through and they said, you got 48 hours to read this. It's yours. If you want it, you got to be on a plane from Sundance to Vancouver. Let me know. And I read it and I loved it.
我这儿正好有一个。他随身带着这个呢。几年前我拍过一部电影叫《皇家酒店谋杀案》（Bad Times at the El Royale）。导演是一个我认识很久的人。他以前为WB电视台写宣传片。我去试镜读WB台下一档节目的宣传词。那个可能得到了。不，我那时候在CBS。
And I was like, cool, cool, cool. This is amazing. Uh, who fell out basically? Cause clearly somebody did. No, John. No, somebody did. It was fine. It was Russell Crow, whatever.
也对。也对。所以，呃，然后，我收到了这个工作的邀约，呃，是在圣丹斯电影节期间传过来的，他们说你有48小时来读剧本。角色是你的。如果你想要的话，你得坐飞机从圣丹斯赶到温哥华。告诉我一声。我读了剧本，非常喜欢。
Good, good replacement. I think. Sure. So I got to work with Jeff Bridges, who I've wanted to work with my entire life. And that's always thought was maybe the coolest, coolest guy, you know, even pre big Lebowski, I was just, I was on board. That's no letdown, right? He's a real, that's a high level professional.
然后我觉得，酷，酷，酷。这太棒了。呃，基本上是谁不演了？因为显然有人退出了。没有，约翰。不，有人退出了。没关系。那是罗素·克劳，随便吧。
And so I got to work with that guy for, they shot the whole thing chronologically. Um, spoiler alert. I die in the first act, but I shot all, you know, whatever two and a half weeks of my heart, and it was mostly with Jeff and man, that was a, that was a, and it was a beautiful set. It was super cool. Everybody on it was nice. Um, it was, that was, that was one of the good ones.
我觉得是个好，不错的替代人选。当然。所以我得以和杰夫·布里吉斯合作，我一辈子都想跟他合作。而且我一直认为他是最酷、最酷的家伙，你知道的，甚至在大勒博斯基之前，我就已经是他的粉丝了。这绝对不是什么失望，对吧？他是一个真正的，那是一个高水平的专业人士。
That was really one of the good ones. John, how weird. So you actually, you, you did this movie with a guy who was writing promos at the CW. What a trip for you guys, right? Did you guys acknowledge that? And I, and I knew him through like a little poker league that we played in. Like he was just, he, he hit the big time. Drew Goddard, and he's still making movies.
所以我得以和那个家伙合作了，他们是按时间顺序拍摄整部电影的。呃，剧透警告。我在第一幕就死了。但我拍完了所有，你知道的，大概两个半星期的戏，而且大部分是和杰夫一起拍的，天哪，那真是一段，而且那是一个美丽的布景。超级酷。上面的每个人都很好。呃，那是，那是其中一部好电影。
Oh yeah. He's doing very well. Oh wait, I know Drew, because I, he's Caroline Williams. He's married to Caroline Williams, who's a tremendous comedy writer. She's one of the funniest writers I've ever worked with. There you have it. She wrote on Bo J. Things happen to good people sometimes.
那真的是其中一部好电影。约翰，多神奇啊。所以实际上，你，你拍这部电影的时候，合作的家伙以前在CW电视台写宣传片。对你们来说真是段奇妙的经历，对吧？你们俩聊过这个吗？而且我是通过我们一起打的一个小型扑克联赛认识他的。就像他，他一炮而红。德鲁·戈达德，他现在还在拍电影。
Now you mentioned auditioning to be the voice of, of CW. So the voice, the voice has been something that, that you've been using for a while, then it sounds like, but you've, you've really hit the top of the mountain there with, with Mercedes for how many years now? I think going on 13 now. John Hamm. That's so cool. Yeah.
哦，是的。他现在发展得很好。哦等等，我认识德鲁，因为我，他是卡罗琳·威廉姆斯的。他娶了卡罗琳·威廉姆斯，她是一位极具才华的喜剧编剧。她是我合作过的最搞笑的编剧之一。你看。她给《马男波杰克》写过剧本。好人有时会有好报。
Yeah. That's great. I've, I've, I've outlasted several CEOs and CMOs and 13 years. That's pretty good. It's not bad. Here he comes. Here he comes. Here he comes.
你刚才提到去试镜成为CW电视台的声音。所以这个声音，这个声音你已经用了有一段时间了，听起来是这样，但你在梅赛德斯奔驰那里真的登上了顶峰，到现在有多少年了？我想快13年了吧。乔恩·哈姆。太酷了。对。
It's not professional grade though. I mean, 13 years is good, but it's not professional. It's not professional. It's not professional grade. It doesn't matter. Oh no, we, I think people want to know. I will say for the listeners out there, every now and again, I will get texts from both Jason and Will about some voiceover, something or other, which is, it's, it's a compliment,
对。太棒了。我，我，我熬过了好几个CEO和CMO，已经13年了。这相当不错。还不错。他来了。他来了。他来了。
but it's a left handed compliment. No. No. It's always a, oh, you see, you're doing that too. Good for you. Good for you. Good for you. Real, real happy for you.
不过这可不是专业级别的。我是说，13年是很长，但这不是专业的。这不是专业的。这不是专业级别的。没关系。哦不，我们，我想大家很想知道。我得对听众们说，每隔一段时间，我就会收到杰森和威尔发来的关于某某配音工作的短信，这，这算是一个赞美，
Let me tell you what else is a good, is a good, that Apple commercial that you do is killer. Yeah. That's well done. Come on. Apple, who shot that? By the way, I want DPN director. Another guy I've known for a long, long time through our mutual friend, tall John Schrader, a guy named Wayne McClammy, who now is another guy that came out of the trenches at the WB.
但这是一个反讽的赞美。不。不。这总是带着一种，哦，看，你也在做那个。真为你高兴。真为你高兴。真为你高兴。真的，真的为你高兴。
No way. I'm not kidding. Do you know who shot it? Do you know who the DP was? I don't remember the name of the DP. I'm sorry. Okay. Wait, Johnny, before we let you go, because I know you got to go, I want to know what
我告诉你另一个好东西，你拍的那个苹果公司的广告太棒了。对。拍得很好。拜托。苹果，那是谁拍的？顺便说一句，我要找DP（摄影指导）导演。另一个我通过我们共同的朋友——高个子约翰·施雷德——认识了很久很久的人，一个叫韦恩·麦克拉米的人，他现在也是另一个从WB电视台的战壕里走出来的人。
you're excited about coming up. That's, that's really getting you going. I'll tell you exactly what I'm excited about, because I've said it about four times today. I get to go to Europe for my birthday. Like I turned 50 last year, and it was during a pandemic, and my big celebration was having some people over and standing 10 feet away from them. And I get to go, my gal and I get to go to the Alps for two weeks for my birthday. I've never been, I've never been to Switzerland.
不会吧。我没开玩笑。你知道是谁拍的吗？你知道摄影指导是谁吗？我不记得摄影指导的名字了。对不起。好吧。等等，强尼，在我们放你走之前，因为我知道你得走了，我想知道你
Oh, that's exciting. I've never been to that part of France, and I've never been to that part of Italy. So we're going to, we're going to do it right. You're going to like that a lot. I'm leaving in a week, and I'm very, very excited about that. That's so exciting. George can toss you the keys for the house in Como. Do you see, baby?
对接下来的什么事情感到兴奋。有什么真正让你兴奋的事吗？我来告诉你我到底对什么兴奋，因为我今天已经说过大约四次了。我过生日可以去欧洲了。我去年五十岁生日时，正赶上大流行，我的盛大庆祝活动就是邀请几个人过来，然后跟他们保持十英尺的距离远。我和我的女友要去阿尔卑斯山过两周生日。我从来没去过，我从来没去过瑞士。
You got Como handy? Let me, let me rock it out. It's right there. I promise I'll mop up. Why not? And listen, you can pop down to Zermatt, and you know, where are you going to Switzerland? Switzerland Stade. Stade, yes.
哦，太令人兴奋了。我从来没去过法国的那部分，也从来没去过意大利的那部分。所以我们要，我们要好好享受一把。你会非常喜欢那里的。我一周后就要出发了，我非常非常兴奋。太让人兴奋了。乔治可以把科莫湖房子的钥匙扔给你。你看到了吗，宝贝？
Nice. I just want to be like, I want to do like one thing James Bond did. Right. Like I want to eat dinner in a like UFO shaped thing that you have to take a gondola to, and then you ski out. Yeah. Dessert. Hey, what are, are you going to get, are you going to get into Germany at all?
你手头有科莫湖的钥匙吗？让我来搞定它。它就在那里。我保证我会把地拖干净的。为什么不呢？听着，你可以去采尔马特，你知道的，你要去瑞士哪里？瑞士施塔德。施塔德，是的。
You should get to Germany and have Mercedes give you one of their cars and drive on the Autobahn where there's no speed limit. Yeah. That's incredible. I think that's a, that's a different trip, but yes, that's going to happen at some point. I'll go on that one with you. Okay. Let's go.
太棒了。我只是想，我想做一件詹姆斯·邦德做过的事。对。比如我想在一个UFO形状的东西里吃晚饭，你得坐缆车上去，然后滑雪出来。对。甜点。嘿，你会，你会去德国吗？
Yeah. Come on. Let's take this podcast on the road and do it German style. But one more thing. And I know that I know the personal life is way more important than anything we do for a living, but I'm just excited about you and your talent. And is there anything that you're excited that's coming up that you can share with us that you're working on or going to work on?
你应该去德国，让梅赛德斯给你一辆他们的车，然后在没有速度限制的高速公路上狂飙。对。这太不可思议了。我觉得这是个，这是个完全不同的行程，不过是的，这迟早会发生的。我要跟你一起去那趟旅行。好的。我们走吧。
The most exciting thing that I have coming out, which will finally come out in May is these long awaited 30 years on sequel to Top Gun. Oh, nice. You're in that? Yes, I am. That's great. And that's coming out, I think Memorial Day weekend around there. And it's, I've seen it.
对。拜托。让我们把这个播客带上路，用德国方式来做。但还有一件事。我知道私生活比我们谋生的任何事情都重要得多，但我只是为你和你的才华感到兴奋。有什么让你兴奋的、即将推出的作品可以与我们分享，或是你正在参与或将要参与的吗？
It's really, really good. It's exactly what you want out of this. And it's, I cannot wait for people to see it. It was one of those things where another kind of pinch me moment, like just like, wait, they're asking me to be in the Top Gun sequel. Like tell my, tell my 15 year old self that. And I would punch my 15 year old self in the face. Yeah.
我最兴奋的作品即将上映，它终于要在五月份上映了，那就是等待了三十年之久的《壮志凌云》续集。哦，太棒了。你演了那个？是的，我演了。太棒了。而且那要上映了，我想大约在阵亡将士纪念日周末前后。我已经看过片了。
So Tom Cruise was not, not a disappointment either. I'll bet, right? Just incredible. The best in the biz, man. The best in the biz. Yeah. As advertised, he is intense and hardworking, but that's exactly who you want. Yeah.
真的非常非常棒。这完全符合你对这部电影的期望。我迫不及待地想让大家看到它。那是那种让我再次想要掐自己一下的时刻，就像是，等等，他们邀请我参演《壮志凌云》续集？去告诉我的，告诉我的15岁的自己这件事。然后我会狠狠地扇我15岁的自己一耳光。对。
That's who you, that's what you want in a, in a Tom Cruise. Oh yeah. That's great. A whole hour on that. That's awesome. Well, I'm excited about that. Johnny, thank you for being here. I know you got to run.
所以汤姆·克鲁斯也不是，也不是个失望对吧？我敢打赌，绝对如此。简直难以置信。业内最棒的，伙计。业内最棒的。对。正如广告所说，他既紧张又努力，但这正是你想要的。对。
It means the world to us and thank you for saying yes to coming on. I'm such a big fan. Thank you very much for having me. It's rare that I know all three podcast hosts at the same time. And it's hopefully if a major league baseball gets her act together, we can go. What are we going to do about that? Jason and I have a lovely friendly Cardinals Dodgers rivalry that the Dodgers have had
这就是你想要的，在汤姆·克鲁斯身上。哦，是的。太棒了。整整一个小时都在聊这个。太棒了。好吧，我对此感到很兴奋。强尼，谢谢你来到这里。我知道你得赶时间。
the better of the last few years, but not really fairly. You still have Flaherty though. You know, listen, you got, you got the ring. You give me him and all's forgiven. Okay. I'll trade you for Walker Biela, I mean with the high school out here and no, no, no, he needs to be with Walker. Oh anyway, we'll talk.
这对我们意义重大，谢谢你答应来做客。我是你的超级粉丝。非常感谢邀请我。我很少能同时认识所有的三个播客主持人。希望如果美国职业棒球大联盟能振作起来，我们就能去了。我们该怎么处理这件事？我和杰森有一场友好而温馨的红雀队对阵道奇队的竞争，过去几年里道奇队一直占着
We'll negotiate something. No, no, no, please continue on with fucking baseball. All the fucking, let's end on baseball. We can end on the fact that I went on a blind date with Jason's now wife. We can, but that's, we, that's, wait, you did. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. No, he's got to go. I gotta go.
上风，但其实不太公平。你们还有弗莱赫蒂呢。你知道的，听着，你们拿了冠军戒指。你把他给我，以往的事就一笔勾消。好吧。我拿他跟你换沃克·比勒，我是说顶着这儿的高中生名号——不，不，不，他必须和沃克在一起。哦不管怎样，我们会谈的。
I gotta go. That's the name in the next episode. Did you really go on a blind date with Amanda? Ham. Just wink at me. One wink means yes. Two means. Okay.
我们会商量出一个结果的。不，不，不，请继续谈你们他妈的棒球。所有的他妈的，让我们以棒球结束吧。我们可以以我和杰森现在的妻子去过一次盲约结束。我们可以，但那是，我们，等等，你真的去过？等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。不，他得走了。我得走了。
John. All right. Thank you so much, John. Thank you, Johnny. Oh, great to have you. Ham, you're the best. You're the best. Go boroughs.
我得走了。那是下一集的标题。你真的和阿曼达去过盲约吗？哈姆。对我眨个眼。眨一下代表是。两下代表。好吧。
I'll end on the next time. All right. I love you guys. Thank you, buddy. Thank you. Thank you. All right. John Ham is no ham.
约翰。好的。非常感谢你，约翰。谢谢你，强尼。哦，很高兴你能来。哈姆，你太棒了。你太棒了。去布鲁克林。
John is a, is a very humble, classy, solid individual. Solid individual. Yeah. I was super excited that he was coming on. I mean, he's like one of those guys that's, you know, I say it all the time, but to, to about other people, but he, whenever he's in something, you're like, oh, this is going to be great. Yeah.
我以这个收尾。好的。我爱你们，伙计们。谢谢你，兄弟。谢谢。谢谢。好的。乔恩·哈姆可不是火腿（Ham）。
Yeah. He's got a real solid presence. And I really meant it about, uh, about Mad Men watching that and, and truthfully like thinking like kind of know him in like this. How's this going to be watching him in this? It's kind of like Jason watching you in Ozark, which is also a testament to how good you are. He's like, you get into it and you're like, you forget that, you know, the guy, which is,
约翰是个，是个非常谦逊、有品位、踏实的个人。踏实的个人。对。我超级兴奋他能来。我的意思是，他就像那种人，你知道的，我经常这么说，但对其他人也是如此，每当他出现在某部作品里，你就会想，哦，这肯定很棒。对。
it's a hard, it's a higher bar to have to hire. I love that. Yeah. I know. That's so true. Like, and that shows how good it is. Oh, Jay, whenever I, yeah, whenever I watch it, I can't, it's like, I don't, it's transformative as they say.
对。他有一种非常沉稳的存在感。我真心实意地想说，关于《广告狂人》，看那部剧，老实说，就像是，我有点了解他在这种环境下的状态。看他在里面的表现会是什么样？这有点像杰森看你在《黑钱胜地》里的表现，这也是对你演技有多好的一种证明。就像是，你沉浸其中，然后你会发现，你忘了你认识这个人，这，
So congratulations on that. Congratulations to John Ham. So Sean, also, what a great guest, so great having John on. Yeah. He's got a new podcast. Yeah. I was going to say that. He's got a new podcast.
这是一个很难、更高的门槛。我喜欢这样。对。我知道。太对了。就像是，这展现了它有多好。哦，杰伊，每当我，是的，每当我看着它，我都无法，就像是，正如他们所说，这具有颠覆性。
It's called American Hostage and it's on Amazon Wondry. It's fantastic. You got to listen to the trailer. The trailer sounds like an actual movie. It's, it's really, really cool. He's perfect for that. It's really great. He's perfect for that.
所以祝贺你取得这个成就。祝贺乔恩·哈姆。所以肖恩，还有，真是个伟大的嘉宾，请到约翰来太棒了。对。他有一个新播客。对。我正要说呢。他有一个新播客。
Cause he's so good. I meant it when I said like, I watch Mad Men. And to, I mean, how many, you would never think that a series about a pot store would last for how many seasons? Oh no, no, no, you're thinking of, sorry, you're thinking of Mad Men, which is a pot store out here in California. No, it's a different, it's a totally different. Yeah.
叫做《美国人质》（American Hostage），在亚马逊的Wondry上播出。太棒了。你们一定要听听预告片。预告片听起来就像一部真正的电影。真的，真的非常酷。他太适合这个了。真的太棒了。他太适合这个了。
Very honest. Oh, this is, oh, sorry, Mad. So it's an anger management, like a help group. Again, it's just, I honestly, I wish you could, it's just kind of a play on Madison Avenue, guys, of advertising executives. What is that? Oh. Explaining what they do.
因为他太优秀了。我刚才说我看《广告狂人》是认真的。而且，我的意思是，多少，你绝不会想到一个关于大麻店的剧集能拍多少季？哦不，不，不，你想的是，抱歉，你想的是《广告狂人》（Pot Men），那是加州这里的一个大麻店。不，那是完全不同的。对。
I'm missed. But it's like where they, you know, those ad executives, they come up with all the different slogans, like, you know, do this, do this, or like, you're thinking of like, bye. Bye. Menon. Menon. Smart. Less.
非常诚实。哦，这是，哦，抱歉，广告狂人（Mad Men）。所以这是一个愤怒管理，类似于互助小组。再说一次，我真的希望你能，这只是对麦迪逊大道（Madison Avenue）的一个谐音梗，伙计们，指广告高管。这是什么？哦。解释他们在做什么。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbaco. Smart. Less.
我没懂。但这就像是他们，你知道的，那些广告高管，他们想出各种不同的标语，比如，你知道的，做这个，做这个，或者就像是，你想的是，拜。拜。Menon。Menon。Smart。Less。
SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smart。Less。SmartLess是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾尔和本·巴尔巴科100%有机手工打造的。Smart。Less。SmartLess。这个剧集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。